[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui on en a fait aujourd'hui
mais cette fois ci c'est tout les
chroniqueurs de tpm paix confié j'ai une
seule personne sur des fringues à votre
avis tu gilou cette chemise il a pas mis
tout seul il savait pas mais en fait il
était filmé et tous les chroniqueurs
langue qui me persuader de mettre cette
chemise mais qui vous va pas mal qui
vous veut pas si mal regardé ce que ça
rend le jeu adore il faut changer ça me
change m'excuser parce que j'avais pas
les malentendus désolé pour hier c'est
cette [ __ ] de benina piégée aurait
gd syrie c'est karl lagerfeld à côté
d'eux
voilà sinon mieux que tu es tu sais quoi
autant profiter de cette vanne et ce
truc là
pour m du coup à ashulia les pieds dans
le plat c'est vraiment la vérité
le seul truc et tout mais vraiment pas
le seul touché watts qui va vraiment
tendu c'est le stylisme 4 cyril pourquoi
il fait je n'ai pas aidé - beaucoup -
mais pourquoi il fait jeunes pareil des
français hyper important ça ça me rend
dingue
tiens ça comme on ne pourra rien à faire
sur la tronche prénom sur le local et je
lis et je pense que c'est surtout
visible et dit je vais bien mauvais ben
saïda là c'est très bien est-ce que je
peux me permettre la perse touche pour
être à la mode aujourd'hui c'était beau
tombions il se faire je veux faire de
toi un world appartient non au visage se
faire sauter tu rigoles baby come back
que ça c'est stylé et pour les gars
c'est mon choix moi on verra
moi je vous dis que cyril va alors et
séducteur days trouvait pas sa boîte
c'est dégueulasse il s'est surtout fait
un merci aux poteaux